[Music]
of yet another african-american man
George Floyd's his murder is why the
country has given us the opportunity to
lead to lead I had my friends on the
other side just said no he has a bike
guy I know how it feels to walk into a
store and have the little clerk follow
me around even as a United States
Senator
I get that I've experienced it I
understand the traffic stops I
understand that when I'm walking down
the street and some young lady clutches
on to her purse and my instinct is to
get a little further away because I
don't want any issues with anybody I
understand that but what I missed in
this issue is that the stereotyping of
Republicans is just as toxic and poison
to the outcomes of the most vulnerable
communities in this nation that's the
issue that was Senator Tim Scott's very
powerful speech on the Senate floor
today after Democrats blocked to the
Senate Republicans police reform bill he
joins us with reaction along with fellow
South Carolina Senator Lindsey Graham
senator Graham he might be giving you a
run for your money in Cavan are there
and and I mean this first of all senator
Scott nobody should be followed in any
store because of the color of their skin
that's got a stop what happened to
George boy can't happen to any human
being nobody should be stopped either
most Americans didn't the 90% of good
Americans agree with that you've met
with the president you talked to the
chief of staff mark meadows you were you
were on the ground asking for the
reforms and as I understand it my
sources tell me everything you asked for
was in the in this bill and more
absolutely I tell you the president's
response to this situation has been
nearly perfect I asked for certain
things in the executive order he went
further I think that Lauren
national database I thought that was
outside of our reach the president said
I want to solve this problem and he did
all we needed to complement the
president's executive order was the
Democrats to show up and be counted
just a few Democrats not 46 just seven
Democrats and we couldn't get seven
people to come to the table and say
they're serious about police report
instead what they're serious about is
using police reform as a campaign issue
this November that is and what and and
what a Joe and Barack do after Ferguson
after Baltimore after Cambridge after
all these did they do anything senator
cuz I don't remember them doing a thing
not that I can recall but I do remember
one thing that Joe Biden did in 1994 he
passed a crime bill that his Democratic
opponent said locked up
disproportionately african-american men
and it's a president Trump to come along
through the first step back and reversed
the carnage the damage the disrespect
done to the black community he reversed
it President Trump made up for the bad
decisions of Vice President Biden you
know I gotta get out of New York I'm
stuck with humor and Gillibrand I could
have senator Scott and Senator Lindsey
Graham and I'd be very happy senator
they haven't done a thing and I know you
are very close as friends both of you
and I watched this today and I'm like
they won't even help the President on
this is there anything they'll do well
if you're talking to me Sean they'll do
whatever it takes to get power if you
need to destroy Brett Cavanaugh's life
to keep the seat open they'll do it what
I did was help Cavanaugh a single
individual being unfairly accused and
being mistreated and having his life
turned upside down to make sure they
could fill the Supreme Court vacancy
what Tim did today is in the face of
hatred you cannot believe I got a lot of
things thrown my way during Cavanaugh
it was pretty dicey nothing compared to
what Tim Scott has gone through what
have I learned about Tim Scott he speaks
from the heart he can't be intimidated
and he's trying to solve a problem he's
he's experienced things I have not
experienced because I'm white I'm from
South Carolina
Tim's from South Carolina and Tim took
to the floor the United States Senate
today to make it better particularly for
young black men and Chuck Schumer
basically told us to go to hell we care
more about the election than we do
working with Senator Scott probably you
know a low point in my career right on
par with Cavanaugh you know something
senator Scott I like to look at Joe
Biden's been in politics nearly 50 years
you mentioned his past what about his
past on segregation and and praising
Robert Byrd
he hasn't it right that's his past also
Lyndon Johnson counted on Republicans
for the 64 Civil Rights Act the 65
Voting Rights Act and and I'm looking at
okay well
Barack and Joe gave us 17 million more
Americans on food stamps 8 million more
in poverty the lowest labor
participation rate since the 70s the
worst recovery since the 40s the lowest
homeownership rate in 51 years and
Donald Trump gave us record low
unemployment for every demographic group
including African Americans and African
American youth
Opportunity Zones that they didn't give
us in the eight years they had power add
to that criminal justice reform add to
that no prison reform a historic black
colleges I like actions you know and
higher labor force participation rate in
the african-american community not only
did we have unemployment under six
percent for the first time on the
president truck for african-americans we
have the lowest unemployment rate
code-free koban 19 for african-americans
for respect for Asians a six-year low
for women we had this economy on fire
because President Trump understands that
free markets lead to great opportunities
for everybody
literally all the boats were rising this
is what so frustrating the Democrats
continue to have a monopoly on minority
votes and they continue to deliver
nothing in return for the monopoly it's
a devaluation of a significant part of
the American family and that's got to
stop
I got to move to South Carolina Lindsay
and we can all go to hall steak house
together amen and you can pay Scott
today very proud of it
I'm proud of both you keep fighting for
justice for everybody